that's crucial
julius randle drives goes inside falling
away puts it up
shot no good and now the knicks have to
foul knock it away robinson has it
boy bodies all over the floor and now
they call a loose ball foul on the
knicks
there was a lot of contact on a number
of those plays
he could dollar lackadaisical he had the
ball they knocked it away from him
and then the ensuing scuffle butler
looked like he got the worst of it
looked like uh burks ran over
butler trying to get to the rebound it
looked like the knicks after randall had
missed the shot that they were
intentionally fouling because a little
bit all the time that went off the clock
versus butler's playing look at him
he's not hurt he's playing like he was
hurt
i'm just having some fun right but they
got the call i think then they might
they gave me
yep it was called against the knicks
watch randall off balance
but watch nicole has the ball didn't
protect him randall just whacked a good
dollar
it was randall who ran over butler
all right watch here there's the foul
there but also mitchell robinson was
fouled by olynyk
i mean there were three or four fouls
before the one they called there
randall's just mauling and appalling
them that time sometimes you see that
when
when nobody has nobody has real
possession
they let it go this time that butler
didn't do it he got it right
so now butler is going to shoot the
again the foul is called
against julius randle